people will change what they think of us
and me when we win games that's I'm yeah
I'm a realist when it comes to that and
I get it and you know what one you don't
win I expect what's written and said and
what people think
I expect fans to be upset because we are
to Pat Shermer in the aftermath of his
latest loss eight in a row he's 7 and 21
through 28 games Ben McAdoo got fired
for being 13 and 15 through 28 regular
season games and he took the team to the
playoffs for crying out loud so there's
a lot of questions about Pat schirmer's
future as head coach of the New York
Giants some answers yesterday from Steve
Tisch co-owner of the team we never hear
from him we always hear from John Mara
here's Steve Tisch at a March of Dimes
event on Tuesday talking about the
future of the franchise the direction we
take the team hopefully in 2020 will
result in a much better season next year
do you think get on and tremor are the
guys that can lead you those decisions
aren't going to be made today so
respectfully so the only thing we know
now is we're not going to see Pat
Shermer or Dave Kellerman get fired
during this season but it sounds like
everything's on the table guys when the
season ends and we touched on this
earlier about the possibility of Ron
Rivera ending up with the Giants but
regardless of who the next coaches it's
looking like Peter it's not going to be
patched Shermer you know we'll see I
think that's why the one thing I learned
I covered the Giants for four years in
the 80s and the one thing I did learn is
that the paying customers were very very
important to the mayor of family what I
mean is that you might think right now
that these are meaningless games John
Mayer does not think these are
meaningless games the fans in the stands
will tell him whether there are any
number one and their tenor I think right
now if I were to guess the Giants would
be inclined to make a change
I mean Pat Shermer won nine games in two
years coaching the Cleveland Browns back
in there you know Sewer days and now
right now he's won seven games in two
years with his hand-picked quarterback
in the future playing this year on an
eight-game losing streak and looking
worse you know I shouldn't say looking
worse every week but you know he is not
Daniel Jones has not made the progress
he should have made so I think the
biggest question for the Giants you know
I think they got three questions do we
give this team one more year as it's
currently constituted with Dave
gentlemen and Pat Sherman and I think
and then the other two do you change one
or do you change the other and I think
the last four weeks of the season you
might laugh at me for saying this but I
think they these last four games are a
factor collectively in what happens and
what decision the Giants are gonna make
yeah it's it's interesting and you know
I think if you you made me bed right now
I'm saying Pat schirmer's not there and
Dave kettlemans not there either I just
that would be my gut feeling on the
situation I mean hey the product on the
field hasn't been good Pat Shermer he
does not endear himself to the New York
media or the fan base here in the
tri-state area so they're not in love
with him there Dave Gettleman certainly
made a lot of questionable moves as far
as free agency you know draft there's
been some good but there's been some
horrible I mean Daniel Jones yeah I
think he hit it out of the park I was
wrong about my evaluation I think he's
the guy but into that to where it goes
back to Pat Shermer I mean the games on
Daniel jones shoulders every week like
he's like John Elway in 1989 I said
every week if he doesn't pull out magic
and for rabbits out of his butt they
can't win a game so that's not fair what
they do to him but I think there's
issues all over the organization as a
Giants fan and just to my friends that
are Giants fans I think everybody's
frustrated and I you know I guess I what
I'm saying is I would clean house and
start over and start a new regime there
in New York we should have known this
wasn't gonna go well with Pat Shurmur
when he was being considered for head
coaching jobs after a great run is
Vikings offensive coordinator his boss
in Cleveland Mike Holmgren said that he
needs to lighten up now if Mike Holmgren
is telling you you need to lighten up
you're probably a little too intense and
that seems to be one of the things
dragging down strimmer here's the other
thing guys if you get a new GM and a new
head coach who's to say they're gonna
want Daniel Jones they may have had a
very different evaluation of Jones and
may want to find a different quarterback
which kind of screws everything up Peter
I doubt that'll happen I'm sure that
they're not gonna want to start from
Ground Zero again they're gonna want to
hire somebody if they do make it change
who believes in Daniel Jones yeah I
think if you don't believe in Daniel
Jones you're probably not gonna get the
second interview that's where I go to
and I do think Mike even if you didn't
love him in the college process they're
gonna watch the NFL film this year and
go man it was pretty damn impressive I
mean let's not you know a lot of people
out there can't even name some of the
receivers he's played with this year
they haven't been able to run the ball
they can't protect so I'm with Peter I
think it'll be about liking him and
making him flourish
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports